hey guys San Francisco here got out of
New York before the storm and made Allen
here or CFO cancel his trip to London
and basically this is going to be you
know a lot of people been talking about
different looks for daily be this will
be a different look like I'm going to
sit here now and we've been sitting here
for an hour and a half and we're going
to do for the next five to seven hours
we're looking at the financial impacts
of our business know running up the
Bainer acts with the pure well and
vaynermedia will talking about over 150
million dollar and fifty and so there's
a lot of workers a shitload of Excel
sheets here that are not necessarily
interested in but the work has to be
done and when you get to this scale and
you get to 800 people you know there's a
lot of inefficiencies especially when
you're building culture and so I'm just
looking at the financial impacts of the
business so this is about as boring this
enough selfies this is not fun quotes in
the interview that's not the stage
people rushing it this is not be rock
waving this [ __ ] hand in the camera
this is [ __ ] real work the true life
behind being a CEO the big company
garyvee daily duties are like side
hustle this is what I do for a living
somebody born the [ __ ] out of you in
today's episode I'm mommy driving not
bad
come back like a visible attack see with
clarity husband like my name is Gary
Thomas I've been telling your accountant
celebrity I'll triple they've given a
pedigree to convene an official my
faculty putting the work that I've done
are the moving furniture
[Music]
all right the night down thank you my
count I got my cell right right oh well
20 minutes that's what it is too many
men here killed everybody was more
people to everybody and everyone say I
like the different into picked out paint
to paint in the first debate or maybe
that's how I drank or maybe that were a
lot containing them to live in it for us
twenty role because instead I take your
life you save myself when the pressure
was resting on my courses like Danny
I never second-guess my sanity I knew I
was crazy but that crazy was good
because that crazy was tough they try to
cause the pharmaceuticals to be forming
high but I just give me don't like the
hard work that you can have a sneaker
bagging on that because they didn't have
the with a new relationship the two
hundred actions I had with him I was
like brother like you've got to pay your
dues no like that's what we all you know
and the lack of patient I think of
the Italian family planning this
[Music]
yesterday another one okay great Alan
are sitting here we're going through
everything on what I want to do is on
Mondays off sides with this week I want
to leave
is it wrong to think that I can change a
whole generation on me my mind is racing
I'm impatient interesting how does
hiring and president I think
metamorphosis mostly employs that I saw
Bianchi a I'm thinking Paul Beck nothing
is falling so I'll bet you my dreams it
seems the means or complex or complex
and I've done and not becoming obsessed
I'm lucky I have my heart for a start-up
in that day I'll play with words that
curb and then shadows I'm learning
pretty crazy exposure miss after battle
the lighting in the night in that I
wanted to capture but I still don't use
dacosta's or something it's doodle
rapture but hopeful do it just in the
mezzanine or UW in San Francisco running
a business how we do it if you haven't
seen the video I made for all 22
year-old Taylor Blaine episode 244 of
the askgaryvee show these new rock color
have some videos right now actually put
the video right here anyway
if you watch it it is
I mean
[Music]
[ __ ] love this is it just like you
know how you're talking about the battle
scars in the blood in the mouth and
loving it this is what's happening right
now there's plenty of battle scars and
blood in the mouth but I love it you
know it's hardcore a lot of political
feelings everybody's protecting their
worlds and trying to advance it all this
but that's the [ __ ] job I have because
the buck stops with me all problems on
this guy allow you to edit this very
smartly which is like for example this
call pay so April 1st just leveled back
to my map defective music music
whimsical caps on everything that's all
those hello slow down when a you know
hey people perfect me hug I would have
goddess of words and balloon like it
worse until it got worse she's got it
this video right now filming all what
everything straight back you know what
it's a bad angle in severely affect the
way to get my whole head there fast
I got it that was wild baby seats
betrayed every Center but not right with
me suggested for the play
[Music]
okay so couple great forgot all the
concert immediately and in fact let me
okay love me
action cloud onwards my preference would
be to get you ASAP preferably when the
Royals are at home so that I can watch
watch some lycra and see baseball
players play that night that'd be fun
for me
plus I'm going to bring Marcus who I'm
going to be in fantasy baseball this
year so be nice to have him there and
make fun of him so let's try to get a
date ASAP so so something in the next so
list maybe you'll work with with a
Marcus or Dennis and then my assistant
Tyler and we should try to get there in
the next within the next thirty days
does that sound right you guys there
Hey so hey so guys real quick I think
that there's going to be a remarkable
product in your two worlds of consulting
and now this Manor that you're going to
be doing I know and I think it's
historical set under the way we thought
Dennis of like consulting but now that
doesn't scare myself with your every
question things that I once accepted now
I don't see it extreme enough
I guess aside for how I acted the past
when I see what you meant when you just
don't
Your Honor I cannot you know used to
growing like I do coming down your
bracket I hope there maybe someday we'll
be coolest air but yet I understand how
that many on it I do love you will never
see you again stuff and not the question
if you about me as your chair so but I
don't show you meeting for 30 minutes
for me as well you know if you don't go
I love you my way around like I'm not no
[ __ ] more detail by out there oh my
god when we talk to me
it was cool when it was good we
understand
really pad and I've had a favorite Oh
mom you know something
[Music]
'we now
[Music]
all in on its on the largest related
issue I don't kind of paper when I get
really [ __ ] serious when I'm doing
like hardcore work or like getting ready
for a few baseball back that's about the
only time I'm not giving up pretty lane
up
Victoire now look at the orbs right so
like I just what am I going to court in
yourself then you wonder over does it
take a minute are you checking on me you
know you ask yourself how do they have
in your way but in everything changed
why do I care about you why don't you
get in so face by having it plain funny
deprecated change literacy
you know there's like RP just really
Sunday's Russell it because prosecutors
things everywhere I know where the stuff
like that exciting
wow that's really got to me but you can
review every real pleasure for you how
are you I'm Gary nice to meet you
awesome it I think you've been hello
sure yeah any like advise that you did
from us today 22 years old yeah I mean
you know my stance or is only two things
that matter hard work and patience your
kids but it's great that you realize
it's going to take actual work
it's good man declined never get down on
yourself putting the work but you know
it's super achievable all within
yourself if you were you
and only for some shopping
by worrying about what other people
think you know
why not a real pleasure nowhere anymore
thank you say hello
I wish you well bye-bye nice we don't
know what just happened I was on the
space we were you know we were doing but
it wasn't like they don't know how to
they don't say that it go they don't
have everything they just watching the
show won a half your size we now have a
full name for the Vayner internal day
daily good I got a cutting skipped out
versus the daily digital deep dive I
want that ball to be the film font and
the same way and then the all the DS and
the Namath to be green got it yeah
so it's either either snow wearing
stories either pick the first ponder the
second volume I'm not Santa Claus right
around you send me on my way
I know you think Ellie now you checking
on me no you asking yourself I know you
wonder already now you take care
are you checking on me now you asking
yourself what do they have in this way
but in everything change my can I hear
about you but on these get it the old
amazing is rational the colpepper fine
and everything you can do we're
literally go away
[Music]
mommy don't that's the beauty there's no
reinforcement of course where you will
meet you you know
you're building a corner
so guys I'm sitting here I'm talking to
Alan let's show Alan and Alan Alan has
been a remarkably successful you know
corporate CFO and you know I think it's
last pl study rail was a 500 million
dollar holding company like you know not
as first buck in roadie Ellis we're
doing a lot of stuff here and you know I
told him like no we're just talking I'm
just me rock just said I want more
insight on here's very simple when you
go culture that's why honey first honey
Empire instead of Empire honey when you
have a honey Empire and your direct
reports are blindly bought in because
we've done everything right to prove
them to trust you you can do big
structural changes big strategy changes
degree or big fundamental the company if
I II know my direct reports my leaders
tomorrow and said we're now selling
actual honey like we are no longer an
agency we now produce honey I just
bought a Honey Farm and and you know how
pasa Robles and and we now sell honey
and I just think eighty percent over me
like okay like what what am i doing like
like yes yes comma so when you build
culture and you build trust you can go
fast you can do things fast we're about
to do six months worth of work
politically in six hours and that's
special and that's the difference and
that's a that's how you win and that's
where big companies die and when you
start getting into you know nine figures
hundred million plus you get bigger and
get slow and when you're the CEO you are
you've got to have that buy-in from your
constituents to be able to get the [ __ ]
that you want done and and on the flip
side a lot of corporate CEOs spend too
much time worrying about the politics
and their constituents which then crease
non-action which then creates failure
for me I know I'm going to get nine
point three out of ten constituents on
board with what I'm about to do and the
point seven will be here because there's
no option have the wind speeds part of
the equation
yes I'm basically making a show for the
19 year old mate I basically am creating
daily like this is the show I would have
watched at 17 16 19 and 22 and be like
oh oh and the growth the growth I'm
getting some people on email like you I
know you feel it
cigarettes cook the game's gray and
everybody thinks it's black and white
you know
[Music]
Bailey Digital side fairly difficult
he's got beautiful
here we go
Oh
what up Instagram rainy Gary I know
daily digital these guys
Bailey's digital deep dive daily digital
defense daily digital decides the
classic we finally came up with a name
for our vaynermedia all-day immersion in
New York City for the 4d experience for
the experience you like that huh afford
the experience daily digital deep dive
8:00 a.m. till 7:00 p.m. in New York
City $10,000 $10,000 ahead we're
debating between 10 and 12 people for
today and I'm excited about it so I know
a lot of you already signed up from
Instagram and I'm excited see desert so
I'm not in New York as you can see no
snow and in San Francisco body coach
good to see you
so what have you learned about your
failures Angelo
angel I like my failure I don't know I
learned whatever the [ __ ] I needed to
learn in that situation try not to do it
again you don't think about failures a
lot of people make the same ones over
and over just a DNA thing anyway how you
guys doing back in London in a month or
so good to see you in how many of you
guys are in for the UH for the daily
digital deep dive how many of you are
coming to that
how many signed up at email you're
getting an email any day soon from for
me with the details
$10,000 ahead no bunch of you are coming
to do that want to get a sense of how
many of you are in Scott even let's go
oh yeah by the way real quick for all of
the people that sign up now and by the
way email me at Gary at vaynermedia
comma Lizzie's at 100
Kyler's 185 is exporting nice vlog good
to see you man sir did you find
block them to the screen gay man yeah I
know are you look every time yeah yeah
Wilson goodness amen
success memory question I'm tired
Bethany can somebody three years ago
Roxy would you may when you just don't I
can't blame you for acting the way you
act in there I guess I'm sorry thank you
baby
I like the talk [ __ ] meet everybody 167
159 that's great yeah probably closest
knows only for 167 to 159 in a
basketball game that's a lot oh wow I
[Music]
mean no you don't fulfill many more of
this soul deep thinking
operation folks my greets nuts all
especially for us business very good
time to wrap up this week you met it
make it real cool a lot of editing the
way we want to do it at least the way I
wanted to see you come out are you gonna
edit it want to go and start editing
[Music]
okay you got more work to do here more
selfies on it nah nothing on validation
yes I tell ya like me there okay good
night support yeah I am yeah I'm here
Baku Baku yeah
oh man okay I don't bloody somebody
putting screech open hi to your daddy
I am today Hosni yeah okay alright yep
you got it
or you looks good I bet again
Baco thank you guys take care of the
other stuff all right
[Music]
maybe I wanna hunt down rain calling
myself now I'm sure he's dr. liking you
Wow I'm not smelling my way around
videos while I was down babe